are you ready to revolutionize your
morning do you know those old boring
coffee mugs with the handle we here at
kerfy Moog systems have been hard at
work to solve this earth-shattering
problem after years of feverish research
and design we present you the Merv our
scientifically engineered coffee
container for an efficient enjoy event
time for your most epic coffee ever
[Music]
wow time to enjoy some coffee ow oh [ __ ]
ow I can't hold properly wow this sucks
we had coffee mug systems have heard
your valuable feedback therefore we came
up with a high-tech insulating thermal
sleeve made of elastic vibranium now you
can hold your mug time to enjoy your
epic morning
here the coffee gets under the [ __ ]
sleeve I can't even ew it's flowing out
of the bottom you it's [ __ ]
disgusting here I at normal coffee mug
systems I've come up with an epic
solution wow look at that I'm holding
the mug without burning my fingers
middle finger wow incredible ring finger
the tricks you can do with this thing
incredible I've revolutionized my
morning the Epic 420 hyper handle wow
even Tony Stark uses it in one of those
Batman movies unbelievable so with that
little example in mind the Swift series
Gondola system and why it's incredibly
stupid Swift series is here to
revolutionize transportation and real
estate an Innovative Gondola system
combines autonomous pods with
lightweight fixed cable infrastructure
to move passengers efficiently with
significantly lower cost per mile and
less emissions than traditional options
as a rule of thumb a tech company using
phrases like revolutionized
Transportation or autonomous pods should
set off all sorts of alarm Bells inside
your head but let's not jump the gun
let's see what they came up with okay so
it's an urban gun dollar system and the
whole idea seems to be the little risk
passengers above streets avoiding
congestion the pods would also be fully
individualized I know this because I
asked yes it would be fully
individualized service these stations
would be on sightings of the main line
it is hard to see in the graphics we
have right now but as a pod stops it
basically pulls over off the main line
this allows any part behind it to
continue along and encumbered right so
what we're looking at here is an Uber on
wires basically now what is wrong with
this idea if you look at the animation
these things go rather slow maybe 20
kilometers per hour meaning they are
only suitable for short distance and the
lower end of middle distance can we
think of a mode of individualized urban
Transportation perfect for short-term
little distances yeah it's called a
bicycle case in point in their promo
video they show a dramatic reenactment
of a person using Swift through an app
I've nailed down the approximate
locations punch them into Google Maps
and would you look at it it's an 8
minute bike ride so instead of building
Towers oil tracks stations and pods and
also maintaining them you can just paint
a bike lane
now on their website they promise things
like efficiency nonstop rides and
flexible routes move passengers in high
volumes this statement is not true and
betrays a phenomenal misunderstanding of
Transit from Swift do you know what
other Transportation method has big
metal boxes offering non-stop rides and
flexible routes cars and they are the
most inefficient space and energy
wasting Transportation there is
individual motorized vehicles are an
inherently wasteful way of moving lots
of people and Swift is no exception as
for the rest of these promises a
citation needed but how do you create an
efficient system that moves passengers
in high volumes let's see if some good
old common sense will give us a solution
if we look at any congested City we can
quickly identify busy routes along which
a lot of people drive and points of
interest that a lot of people want to go
to now get this if you build a Transit
line along that busy route and Transit
stops at or near points of interest a
lot of people will take that Transit
instead of sitting in traffic jams for
two hours trams trains and buses move
far more people than Ubers as it turns
out even if the Uber is suspended in the
air but we can't have tram strains and
buses because that would violate the
holy status goal of car dependence if
you look at Swift's renders their system
is his biggest selling point is freeing
up Urban space goes above a five-lane
road for cars if we're so concerned
about inefficient Urban space use why
not take away a lane or two from cars
and convert them to bus lanes dedicated
tram lines or separated bike paths which
would then move far more people well
because as I said that would violate the
core-centric state of school you would
think a transportation Revolution would
entail breaking the status quo and not
abiding by it you know welcome to the
American Revolution where we recognize
King George as a rightful ruler and our
radical goal is to put up a U.S flag
next to the British colonial office if
they let us and we periodically see
Transit ideas like this the straddling
bus was one of them the sky bus would
have been something like that even the
diet inside Shadow a black hole of
intelligence and creativity has come up
with multiple projects like Swift and
they're all equally stupid as you can
see Swift is suffering from a number of
issues so let's go ahead and fix them
first off the wires are a terrible idea
especially since the pods would be
self-propelled usually cable cars are
attached to the wire and there is a big
engine somewhere that spins a wheel that
moves the wire thus the cabins if the
ponds are self-propelled however their
wheels are would wear out the steel
wires very quickly leading to frequent
and expensive Replacements so let's have
a solid steel rail instead like on this
promotional render of theirs thereby
cutting down on wear you can also
combine it with a power source wire
inside the rail so the pots don't need
batteries to run which they presumably
would have otherwise now those Towers
look nice and slick but they would be
too expensive not to mention our system
would then be vulnerable to high winds
and would need to be shut down during
storms and so on maintenance would also
be difficult since you would need to
show up with a truck holding a crate and
a basket to do any work rescue would
also be complicated if a pod breaks down
you would need to call the fire
department to evacuate people therefore
I propose to transfer the system to
ground level eliminating all the
aforementioned issues now efficient
space use is very important to us
thankfully there are five car Lanes
still which we can easily convert to
Dedicated pod Lanes which will move a
lot of people increasing efficiency now
we can skip the wires and poles by
putting the rail on the ground and we
can immediately have two even for any
stability we can also move the power
from inside the rail to above the pods
for easier and cheaper maintenance and
increased safety now the individualized
transit idea is q food as in our pods
operating like automatic Ubers but
that's not efficient enough let's build
our line along a busy Corridor with
pre-planned intermediate stops so that a
lot of people can get on and off
wherever they want for this highly
efficient operation however the pods are
too small so let's join our pots
together into one big long articulated
pod with lots of doors and much higher
capacity join us at tr4m systems for
this incredible new mode of Transit no
one has thought of before I have truly
revolutionized Transportation
congratulations to me I guess and
congratulations to you for watching if
you like my content please consider
supporting me on patreon I sometimes
post pictures of my cats there for
everyone's enjoyment thank you for
watching and I'll be seeing you next
time